[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
premier rendez vous de la semaine on a
quatre sujets assez passionnant en tout
cas j'espère à vous proposer et les
voici en images sans plus tarder on va
évidemment revenir sur la commémoration
du centenaire du 11 novembre 1918 7 et
hier emmanuel macron a sonné le tocsin
attention dit il
les nationalismes reviennent et il faut
s'en inquiéter
alors ma crois qu'il fait progresser la
paix hier on se posera la question qui
s'intéressera aussi à donald trump qui
était l'un des invités d'honneur de
cette journée
trump qui twitte à tort et à travers
peut-être qui enfume emmanuel macron et
sa femme dans la cour de l'elysée est-il
mal élevés pas seulement dans le style
bien sûr mais aussi dans sa façon de se
comporter
politiquement on parlera aussi du
salaire de jean claude mailly l'ancien
patron de force ouvrière
cent mille euros par an c'est ce qu'on
vient d'apprendre comme on a appris que
les membres des cabinets ministériels du
gouvernement d'edouard philippe sont
rémunérées en moyenne neuf mille euros
par mois est ce que c'est normal compte
tenu de leur travail de leur talent ou
est-ce que c'est trop bas on
s'interrogera là dessus et puis nous
nous intéressons aussi au gilet jaune
il compte bien bloquer la france samedi
prochain sont ils pour reprendre
l'expression de jean luc mélenchon des
fâché ou des fachos on verra ça tous
ensemble avec nos invités bonsoir
elisabeth lévy vous êtes journaliste
bien sûr directrice de la rédaction de
causeur votre magazine qui consacre son
dernier numéro à nos confrères du monde
à l'occasion du livre de paris par paru
pardon sur l'islamisation de la
seine-saint-denis livres 2,2 et que
journaliste célèbre du monde messieurs
davet et l'homme maintenant par france
culture et maintenant par la mise à
minassian sur france culture
vous êtes aussi l'auteur derrien pensant
votre dernier livre publié aux éditions
du cerf nicolas bouzou et là aussi bon
soit enfin cet économiste fondateur du
cabinet de conseil asterès vous êtes
l'heureux auteur heureux parce que c'est
un gros succès de librairie avec julia
de funès du management
ou la comédie inhumaines c'est aux
éditions de l'observatoire il paraît que
vous avez dépassé les 48 d'exemple je
crois bravo respect et maurice szafran
et là aussi bon soir maurice vous êtes
journaliste co fondateur de marianne
éditorialiste à challenges vous est
aussi chroniqueur à lci où j'ai le
plaisir de vous retrouver chaque jeudi
dans l'émission le débat d'arlette
chabot et notre confrère à l'action de
vu qu il a aussi bon soir à l'export
vous êtes le patron du figaro vox c'est
vous qui régné sur le débat d'idées et
des pages débats opinion du figaro avec
plein de gens qui sont travaillés avec
vous vous êtes aussi l'auteur des
nouveaux enfants du siècle
ça a été publié aux éditions du cerf on
commence tout de suite par s'intéresser
à une partie du discours d' emmanuel
macron hier même si on commémorer un
événement historique la fin de la
première guerre mondiale
emmanuel macron a fait de la politique
avec un grand p c'est à dire qu'il s'est
intéressé aux affaires du monde et de
façon assez inquiétant de voir alarmiste
écouter l'extrait du discours qu'il a
prononcé hier c'était au forum de la
paix nous sommes divisés par les retours
des passions tristes le nationalisme le
racisme l'antisémitisme l'extrémisme qui
remettent en cause cet horizon que nos
peuples attendent
alors est ce que cette comparaison est
opportune s qu'effectivement on sert la
cause de la paix en dénonçant les
nationalistes mais bien avant d'ouvrir
le débat
je vous propose d'écouter ce point de
vue intéressant c'est celui de luc ferry
le philosophe et ancien ministre de
l'éducation nationale il était ce matin
sur la matinale de radio classique le
figaro et en réfléchissant au
nationalisme il ya cette intervention
qui commence par une analyse politique
et qui se termine par une grosse claque
à emmanuel macron regarde il ya le
nationalisme français qui est un
universalisme et donc quand un orri
guaino a à droite ou un jean pierre
chevènement à gauche où quentin régis
debray ou un alain finkielkraut
défendent aujourd'hui les frontières ou
les des nations c'est pas dans l'optique
de la haine de l'autre ce sont des
univers
réduire le nationalisme à la haine de
l'autre est une absurdité
donc on peut pardonner dans la bouche
d'un romain gary parce que c'est dans un
contexte où il a fait une guerre
effroyable contre le nationalisme aux
nazis c'est ça qui le visent
mais leur dire aujourd'hui que c'est
tout simplement une bêtise maurice
szafran serait une bêtise de absolument
pas une bêtise vous disip faire
progresser la paix pendant ce week-end
évidemment que non
mais il a posé il a posé les bonnes
questions on a légitimement un le droit
de les poser et deux de penser
qu'effectivement dans un certain nombre
de pays dans un nombre de régimes en
europe et ailleurs est effectivement un
retour des patientes risque un retour du
nationalisme et non pas du patriotisme
moi en tout cas dans mon éducation on a
expliqué y compris dans les écoles de la
république que le patriotisme et le
nationalisme ça n'avait rien à voir il y
à un retour du racisme il ya autour de
l'antisémitisme ce sont des vraies
questions et je ne vois pas au nom de
quoi le président de la république s'il
le pense et je suis absolument certain
qu'il est totalement sincère je ne vois
pas au nom de quoi il n'aurait pas le
droit
1 demain de poser ses questions et de le
dire on a le droit de donner de ne
donner wild craig est alors totalement
mais il a tout à fait et c'est son rôle
de dire ce qu'il a dit hier complètement
elisabeth la vie est ce que vous
partagez ce diagnostic en l'occurrence
il passera d'abord je voudrais dire ah
bon mais ses rapports avec mon propos
que moi j'ai été très touché par la
ferveur des gens je veux dire dans cette
commémoration dans l'idée qu'on
célébrait d'abord on ne l'a pas beaucoup
dit quand même une victoire de la france
et s'ils voulaient
je pense que on peut en dire beaucoup de
choses mais renvoyer tout le monde dos à
dos en permanence et faire comme s'il
n'y avait jamais eu d'affrontements
armés à lapin me paraît pas c'est pas en
effaçant même le souvenir de la guerre
voilà mais bon là dessus avec ans mais
sur le diagnostic parce que je pense
qu'il ne comprend pas la mesure de cela
c'est à dire que macro ne prend pas la
mesure de la force de la force
incroyable de l'amour pour son pays de
ce sentiment que moi j'appelle le
sentiment national parce que dans ce
qu'il appelle le nationalisme si vous
voulez et oui parce que moi je ne crois
que dans ce qu'il appelle le national y
et ne voit pas moi aujourd'hui la
poursuite un continuum avec le
nationalisme d'entre les deux guerres il
n'y a pas de partie de la guerre le
retour des patients traités en parle
tout le temps de boire d'eau être
honnête je suis trop longue suis
d'accord je vois juste aussi une volonté
des peuples
l'expression d'une volonté des peuples
de rester des peuples
je ne vois pas une haine si vous voulez
des autres pays
je vois tout simplement que l'europe
supranationale de macron si vous voulez
qu'il est derrière tous ces propos sur
l'europe
c'est au rêve se heurte à
l'anthropologie et je crains qu'il n'en
prennent pas la mesure voilà je vois moi
surtout j'ai peur que ça aboutisse à une
façon de dénoncer des peuples et de
mettre dans le même sac
toute personne qui aura une critique ou
une appréhension sur les flux
migratoires sera mise dans le même sac
des plats chauds des racistes et
homophobes etc
et ça ça ne va pas alors évidemment
point de vue étant votre émission nous
vous posons la question sur twitter
macron at-il selon vous fait progresser
la peste en pointant ce sujet ou bien au
contraire est-ce qu'il a exacerbé les
tensions alors ce n'est pas un sondage
associant un vote les gens qui sont en
train de vous regarder et qui est qu'ils
s'expriment mais vous êtes plutôt
critique 1
globalement et voici quelques
commentaires qui accompagnent ces votes
sébastien qui sur twitter nous dit macro
n'a pas compris qu'on ne construit pas
la paix en désignant des ennemis en quoi
aurait-il fait progresser la paix nous
demande le bigot sur twitter au
contraire refus de répondre aux
questions liées à l'identité migrants
islam banlieue alors même si c'est vrai
que c'était pas tout à fait le thème de
la de la journée d'hier et sur le chat
du figaro nicole nous dînons macro ne
fait pas progresser la paix il oppose
les gens en permanence effectivement ça
va c'est à cette alternative pardon que
nous pensions en choisissant ce titre
nicolas bouzou qu'est ce que vous pensez
c'est à dire est-ce que emmanuel macron
ne dresse pas un peu les pays les uns
contre les autres avec ce genre je vais
vous dire moi je suis plutôt d'accord
avec l'idée générale d' emmanuel macron
pas avec les comparaisons l'historique
pas avec les comparaisons historiques
normes et avec le nationalisme et je
vais vous dire le fond de ma pensée
mais vraiment je le dis avec prudence
parce que je veux pas choquer mais
certain nombre de mes amis y compris
qu'ils sont sur le sur le plateau et
dont je respecte éminemment la pensée
bien évidemment mais je n'aime pas le
nationalisme
je suis né en france j'en suis très
heureux mais je n'y suis absolument pour
rien j'aurai la même valeur si j'étais
né en allemagne et je pense que la
grandeur d'un être humain c'est de
s'arracher à ses origines et donc pour
des raisons philosophiques je n'ai
jamais aimé le nationalisme en revanche
considéré que le nationalisme
aujourd'hui celui d' or ban
celui de poutine celui de trump nous
mène à la guerre je pense que c'est
absolument faux je me sens absolument
pas menacée par ces peuples là quand je
lis un discours de victor badges et des
désaccords quasiment sur tout mais
évidemment veut
n'est pas du tout le sentiment qu'il met
au style en tant que français que la
hongrie va déclarer la guerre à la
france ça me pose des sujets qui sont
des problèmes qui sont beaucoup plus
concret et qui sont beaucoup plus
intéressants sur les structures de
l'union européenne par exemple et là on
a un débat qui est très intéressant et
qu'il faut poser voyez donc je réponds
vraiment avec prudence mais je comprends
ce que veut dire emmanuel macron on a
aussi le droit je sais que l'idée de
nation re devient très à la mode je
comprends parfaitement ça mais comprenez
bien que avec un raisonnement
philosophique que je pense assez solide
on a le droit de ne pas aimer nationale
c'est une phrase c'est pas une idée qui
redevient à la mode je pense que c'est
une force motrice dont on aurait la même
perdu le sens de l'existence tellement
elle est importante je vais bien c'est
que politique politiquement les
gouvernements qui ont le vent en poupe
sont des gouvernements qui sont
favorables à cette idée c'est ce que je
voulais dire à qui ça existe si vous
voulez c'est ça que je veux mais
personne personne n'a jamais dit je suis
d'accord avec nicolas personne n'a
jamais pensé il faudrait être fou que
hors ban met en danger la france ou les
pays alentour que sa vie ni dans la
merci des manuels maman que jésus est
sur l importance du matériel médical de
ce qu'on se dit autour de cette table
par contre on peut repenser profondément
que pour le peuple hongrois même s'il a
été élu de façon parfaitement
démocratique je ne supporte plus cette
idée de parce que un responsable
politique quel qu'il soit a été élu par
son peuple bien sûr qu'il était vu par
son peu hors bâle n'a pas fait putsch et
les fascistes en italie n'ont fait aucun
putsch non plus ils ont été élus
parfaitement démocratiquement
qu'est ce que ça change on a là on a le
droit de dire que dans notre conception
des sociétés démocratiques que dans
notre conception des sociétés
occidentales dans notre conception des
sociétés européennes
nous sommes opposés à ce type de rien on
peut s'interroger mais on peut donner
des réponses aux me donner des bonbons
sans questions qu'on pose des actes
juste d'accord avec vous la toile et au
moins mais pourquoi les endroits comme
pour ans contrairement à ce qu'on
emballe qui était de gauche ont bien
besoin aujourd'hui ce qu'il est moi qui
suis un fidèle lecteur du figaro vox
contrairement à ce qu'ont écrit souvent
à ce que des intervenants du figaro vox
écrivent souvent on a le droit de
critiquer monsieur savini on a le droit
de critiquer monsieur roquet qui vous on
a le droit de ne pas penser comme eux et
est réalisé et on a le droit ou non de
l'origine d'accord autour des avancées
autre manga en france de jouer le combat
contre les populistes pas décemment
combat en france au centre on suit vous
voulez mais pas avec 102 avec emmanuel
macron absolument pas dit une bêtise
historique
on y reviendra mais il n'a pas dit une
bêtise politique et effectivement il le
fait c'est une stratégie
il est en campagne pour les européennes
bien sûr qu'il fasse progresser la paix
en déclarant la guerre à ses voisins
italiens ont droit à des criminels mais
on les aime en l'occurrence c'est lui
qui pour le coup qui divise l'europe et
qui insulte quand même les peuples en
les traitant de l'épreuve donc ça ça
c'est une chose dont je suis pas sûr que
dramatiquement c'est extrêmement fin
donc ils préfèrent faire campagne pour
les européennes que d'être dans la
stature du président de la république
aux deux au dessus des au dessus des
partis et est donc je suis pas sûr que
voilà que qui fasse progresser la paix
après sur le plan historique
il a dit une bêtise parce que je suis
désolé c'est pas le nationalisme qui a
causé la seconde guerre mondiale c'est
le totalitarisme et si on veut et on
parle de la première wii et le bruit
mais il a parlé aussi des années 30 dont
il a fait cas un beau bouquet boulga
à incroyable et aujourd'hui si elles
menacent totalitarisme elle n'est pas du
côté de durban ou de salvini qui est-ce
qui aujourd'hui tuer des juifs parce
qu'ils sont juifs en france qui ait ce
qui tue des européens parce qu'ils sont
européens il me semble pas que ce soit
les populistes et nakhon hélas les
branchements il a noyé il parlant de
manipulation des religieux dans sur
cette question non on a cru donc je leur
en a cru que l'homme sait combien on a
cru qu'une sémitisme d'extrême droite
était en recul est en voie de
disparition
on se rend compte qu'en occident c'est
moins vrai qu'on a cru dans soyez soyez
prudent sur cette question l'arnage de
choyer pour lui casser la gueule à
déjouer n'a pas cru qu'il est normal que
lorsqu'on accuse cru classé à l'extrême
que l'église et des collabos et
désaccords de fond sur la nation mais me
semble incroyablement juste il faut le
répéter c'est à dire que parce qu'il
faut quand même qu'on raisonne de façon
de façon saine le nationaux le
nationalisme nahla mais le nationalisme
disons d'avant guerre était un
nationalisme de conquête
aujourd'hui le nationaliste avec un
nationaliste et des veufs de défense et
gars je ne l'apprécient pas mais ils ne
représentent bien évidemment pas le même
danger et alexandre a raison de rappeler
que ce qui menace pour l'essentiel
pardonnez moi de faire cette généralité
mais nos compatriotes juifs aujourd'hui
sont pas en gros on sait très bien que
ce sont les terroristes islamistes
radicaux voilà oui mais dans le coma
super dont emmanuel macron a
parfaitement noyer le poisson il y avait
dedans ils atteignent phrase sur la
manipulation des religions et je ne sais
plus qui nous a parlé d'ailleurs on
était au même débat maurice de bolton à
rodez évangéliste à ma connaissance il
ya pas eu d'attentât de campagne
d'attentats évangélistes où que ce soit
dans le monde donc il ya un moment il ya
c'est quand même difficile locarno il ya
13 malgré que ça fera c'est un resto est
un brin progrès au contraire dans son
évolution sur la façon de faire faillite
il a découvert il a découvert une étoile
et bientôt on verra mais je voulais me
reposer je voulais vous poser une
question
ce qui est extraordinaire à aucun moment
vous dites c'est une opération politique
il est patent attendait à aucun moment
vous n'aimez telle hypothèse que
peut-être peut-être comme ça
oui le dogme politique il croit ce qu'il
y ait là se croisent alors il ya mon nom
c'est une opération d'hernie sienne mais
peut-être qu'ils croient ça veut
peut-être mais à ce moment là il a une
vision anachronique et je le rappellerai
que dans les années 30 c'est la
faiblesse face justement à la montée de
certaines idéologies qui nous a conduit
à la guerre
ensuite ce qui a conduit aussi à la
guerre dans les années 30 c'est le
capitalisme financier dérégulé c'est
bien pour ça qu'après la guerre on a
fait nos modèles sociaux modèles sociaux
qu'aujourd'hui lui et ses amis veulent
détricoter
donc voilà je les joue
[Rires]
gadjo dilo oui et je finis avec janvier
chez ceux qui veulent mettre j'assume ce
qu'ils veulent mettre des limites à
cette montée d'une certaine idéologie et
des limites à une mondialisation qui
détruit les modèles sociaux et le modèle
bellini culturel ceux qui veulent mettre
des limites à cela soit à mon avis
aujourd'hui dans le camp de la paix et
non pas dans celui de la gare vous avez
la créance mais arrêtons ou et le camp
de la guerre franchement je veux dire
arrêter il n'y a pas deux camps la
guerre simplement est-ce qu'on peut
quand même dire un mot il ya derrière il
ya quand même un pacifisme un peu
gentillet chez makro voilà il ya l'idée
non mais par exemple je suis désolé
maurice si j'en crois ce que je lis dans
cet estimable journal qui est le figaro
c'est bien pour faire plaisir à madame
merkel que nous avons décidé de célébrer
afin de pacifisme simplement pas si on
célèbrera ses célèbres une victoire
militaire
c'est en et passons tout souvenir
militaire c'est une forme g2a le cap sur
la resocialisation peut-être la
réconciliation mais on construit pas
leur réconciliation sur la réécriture de
l'histoire je suis désolé que c'est pas
du sang est parti à user d'un sacrifice
où je vais juste alors je le dis très
vite je pense que à force de célébrer
l'amitié franco allemande que je ne
conteste pas sur tous les tons si vous
voulez l'amitié c'est très bien mais
c'est pas ça qui régit les relations
entre les peuples
on n'a plus aucun rapport de forces
c'est ça qui m'inquiète c'est qu'en
réalité
j'aimerais qu'on puisse critiquer aussi
un certain nombre d'exigences allemande
par année sur la gestion de l'euro sur
voilà or j'ai leur pression pour
l'instant que comme hollande macro nous
a dit vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir et que au delà des grandes de deux
des dépôts j'ai trouvé ça très bien
qu'ils aient tous ces chefs d'état je ne
suis pas sûr qu alors que justement
alors d'abord on laisse le dernier mot à
deux internautes on est très
participatif ici babineau qui nous dit
sur le chat du figaro on peut aimer son
pays sans être nationaliste et aulas qui
reprend les propos d'alexandre vécu en
dix ans
qu'on dénonce des pays dits populiste en
traitant les gens de l'épreuve il faut
arrêter de parler comme ça même s'il
faut être précis c'était c'était la
lettre là c'était public qui était
considéré comme la wii
ses dirigeants on comprenait bien ont
été été élu démocratiquement
il est compliqué mais c'est insultant
pour des pays qui sont voisins qui sont
des alliés depuis très longtemps des
dictats dockery c'est celui qui dit bien
été élu des morceaux que sinon bah c'est
pas un avion va un qui n'est pas un
dictateur en irak et démocratique alors
monsieur you et sa lune chers amis nous
allons prendre un exemple d'un de ses
leaders qui peut-être est considéré dans
l'esprit de damon et macro comme un
populiste et donald trump donc donald
trump à son arrivée vous souvenez
vendredi à paris à avait envoyé un tweet
peu aimable le président maquereau en
disant qu' il était insultant parce que
il suggérait que l'europe devait
construire sa propre armée pour se
protéger contre les etats-unis la chine
et la russie
le fait d'être mis sur le même plan a
priori ne lui déplaisait
il ya eu cette réponse en anglais dans
le texte d' emmanuel macron à donald
trump à propos de ce tweet ces têtes
hier sur cnn pour faire avec des
discussions diplomatiques street alors
ça il le débat continue pendant que les
pressions la république par la tension
manque de respect au chef de l'état
est-ce que de la forme c'est mal
comportés globalement pendant ce week
end alors il ya eu des moments un peu
anecdotique par exemple quand il a
démarré sa sa voiture alors c'était pas
lui qui conduit c'est mais sa voiture
blindée qui a donné un nuage de
pollution dans la cour de l'elysée mais
nicolas bouzou est ce que vous trouvez
qui s'est bien comporté par exemple il a
refusé allées dallées au forum de la
paix avec d'autres d'autres chefs de
lennon je pense que donald trump est
quelqu'un qui grosso modo se comporte
mal qui est vulgaire grossier mise
etc je pense qu'on peut être à peu près
d'accord là-dessus mais je pense aussi
que c'est assez secondaire au fond je
pense que le débat qui est posée est un
débat qui est très intéressant qui est
celui de la défense européenne et là il
faut on peut avoir quand même un débat
construit sur ce sujet je pense que
honnêtement les déclarations d emmanuel
macron était sa présentation n'était pas
très bonnes c'est à dire que même si
c'était un peu plus compliqué que ça
mais son idée générale qui consistait à
dire notamment on va se protéger de la
russie je le redis je me sens pas du
tout agressé ni inquiétés par la russie
en tout cas il vient mais en tout cas et
par les états unis évidemment en
revanche non mais c'est plus vis-à-vis
de la russie que la question si mauvaise
que vous avez des états unis elle se
pose bien évidemment pas mais en
revanche je pense que l'idée alors
d'avoir une défense européenne c'est
très difficile d'avoir une défense
européenne c'est pas ça en réalité mais
l'idée de mettre en commun un certain
nombre de ressources pour que nous
puissions faire ensemble des
interventions l'intervention qui a été
réalisé par la france au mali par
exemple c'est la france qui en à
supporter la totalité du coup nos amis
allemands étaient très contents qu'on le
fasse mais c'est nous qui l'avons payé
donc on voit bien qu'il ya quand même un
sujet il ya un sujet extrêmement mais
n'ont pas été faites ça a été fait sur
les opérations de la france donc là là
si vous voulez je pense qu'il ya un vrai
sujet donc c'est un très bon débat que
donald trump soit vulgaire oui alors la
question twitter pensez vous que donald
trump est mal élevé celle que nous vous
faisons et nous vous ne répondez comme
nicolas bouzou pire qu'on va le
découvrir tout de suite à moins qu'il
soit trop tôt pour avoir le résultat du
vote
et bien c'est oui à 63% quelques
commentaires on le juge guerre mais il a
redonné espoir aux américains relancer
l'économie il ne cherche pas à séduire
les médias nous dit dominique sur
twitter et gens debout ajoute trump
n'est pas mal élevés l'école aux états
unis sont assez différents de ceux
d'europe
il représente assez bien la casse
américaine alors moi je vais donner mon
point de vue puis après je m'entraîne
maurice szafran de réagir à ça moi je
trouve que il s'est quand même bien
comportés parce qu'à aucun moment il n'a
dit sur cette histoire de défense que
les etats-unis paient quand même je
crois 700 milliards de dollars par an
pour protéger tous ces chefs de l'état
et donc il n'a pas dit
vous vous foutez du monde donc moi j'ai
trouvé relativement soft traités sont en
question mais n'a aucune n'a aucune
espèce question est ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il a fait de la politique
chacun de ses gestes chacun de ces
retards
chacune de ses sorties le fait qu'ils
sont allés au cimetière américain plutôt
qu'aux formes pour la paix c'est très
clairement des positions politiques où
il s'est démarqué extrêmement clairement
d'emmanuel macro je crois que c'est
aussi c'est aussi c'est aussi clair que
ça donc il ay avoriaz tellement
maintenant oui mais là de nouveau un
trump il a fait ce qu'il pensait juste
de faire c'est sa politique d'accords
alex horne alexandre lévesque est
d'accord avec moi et ça me sera ne peut
réintroduire justement des rapports de
force dans la politique c'est ça a
beaucoup plus important que sa mauvaise
éducation a effectivement les îles et
mal éduqués mais son côté mal éduqués
aussi en politique c'est à dire quand il
n'est pas d'accord il exprime et
symboliquement il dit des choses je
pense que vous avez effectivement
c'était ça qui était intéressant et donc
on à maquereau qui effectivement dans
une vision au multilatéralisme comme
comme il l'a appelé et on a
effectivement donald trump qui fait des
deals pays par pays en fonction de
l'intérêt des états unis d'amérique ces
deux visions effectivement du monde qui
à mon avis ils vont continuer à
s'opposer dans les années à venir c'est
le débat du futur est dit comme ça c'est
mieux que les nationalistes par les
méchants d'assurer lés meilleures
élections mais je pense que vous
surestimez un peu trop nous prend juste
un exemple
qu'est ce qu'il a fait avec l'accord
avec le mexique le canada et caetera et
gladys est horrible c'est le pire accord
qui ait jamais été d'attendre
l'évolution
les accords annoncés pénible et non mais
franchement au milieu d'une phrase c'est
pénible
non pas le bon message de l'agent après
la changer trois trucs et en fait si tu
veux il a fait tout sur machin
ylang-ylang lève il détruit quand même
la confiance qui habite les autres
maintenant juste un mot sur paris
d'abord macron a été effectivement
insultant parce que c'est trop pas donné
beaucoup de signaux comme quoi ils
voudraient que l'amérique se désengage
de l'otan ça c'est tout à fait vrai et
on a le droit de répondre en disant très
bien nous on va se prendre en charge
notre sécurité mais c'est pas
raisonnable de dire à un allié on va se
protéger contre vous donc ça franchement
c'est 1 010 partout mais la deuxième
chose comment dire la deuxième chose
c'est que est-ce qu'on peut dire un mot
sur la défense européenne ue ça vous
intéresse pas du vrai ment 20 secondes
parce que c'est un sujet de débat qui
mériterait un livre bon ben alors non
alors c'est bon alors sur le reste moi
je trouve qu'il a eu raison de bas lieu
à ce truc complètement loisirs
folkloriques du forum pour la peur va
écouter le chef d'état qui doivent se
taper les ong les associations pour
voter sur des projets c'est du foutage
de gueule et que des chefs d'état
acceptent de sacré pied trois heures ne
leur présente pour les autres j'ai mais
bon c'est autonome basque avait l'onu
pour relever votre votre marque et dans
un système démocratique à l'échelle
internationale il est tout à fait
classique que des chefs d'état trt
sommes compris qu'ils sont sur des
lignes dures quand il quand ils
négocient avec les mexicains eux que
c'est bien normal que là que la ligne
dure tout d'un coup deviennent moins dur
c'est comme ça que ça se discute qui les
insultent ah bon oui qui ferait ce qui
crée ce que je crois c'est que le style
n'est quand même pas malgré tout c'est
peut-être pas le sujet principal n'est
sacré même plus assurée chaque beaucoup
ça crée pas beaucoup de confiance et que
je suis je pense qu'en fait il pose les
bonnes questions
très souvent le libre échange le
politiquement correct le un certain
nombre de choses sur l'industrie et je
pense que ça il a raison de poser ses
sujets de l'accord et rania mais
simplement que la façon dont ils y
répondent est souvent compliqué il n'a
pas dit a pas d'alternative pour
l'instant l'accord iranien donc on sait
pas où on va
voilà et là on nous dit trump est rude
mais il défend ses intérêts
poutine aussi et nous que défendons-nous
et puis une réaction de guillaume mais
c'est pas moi sur le chat du figaro
trump c'est du show à l'américaine
permanent nicolas bouzou est ce qu'on
n'a pas au moins gagner en lisibilité et
avec ces nouvelles règles des politiques
intentionnelle ou chacun dit ce qu'ils
pensent emmanuel macron dit qu'il est
inquiet donald trump dit qu'ils s'en
fout non il ya deux sujets il ya le
sujet de la forme est là en fait
d'accord avec ce qui ce qui a été dit
c'est à dire qu'on peut comprendre que
dans une diplomation se disent les
choses clairement
on sent qu'il ya une crise il n'en met
ensuite une vraie question de fond en
revanche qui a été posée par annuel
mâcon qui est celle du multilatéralisme
et moi je pense que nous avons besoin
plus que jamais en réalité du
multilatéralisme parce que je pense que
sur les questions qui sont les questions
primordiales pour l'avenir du monde
question de sécurité une question de
santé questions d'environnement les
questions de régulation des nouvelles
technologies comme vous avez qui
m'intéresse beaucoup
je pense que nous ne pouvons pas faire
autrement que passer par le multi
réalisme et donc je vois bien que les
institutions multilatérales telles telle
qu'elle existe aujourd'hui manque
d'efficacité il est clair que louer nu
on voit bien que ça ne fonctionne pas
bien mais je pense que l'idée de
multilatéralisme
elle est plus que jamais nécessaire mais
c'est très difficile c'est très
difficile parce qu'on est de plus en
plus nombreux c'est très difficile parce
que on a des acteurs qui sont de plus en
plus présent et avec lesquels on n'est
pas habitués à négocier le fait que dans
nos débats par exemple on n'évoque
jamais la question de la chine qui était
en train dans les questions
technologiques en particulier de
l'intelligence artificielle qui est en
train de dépasser des états unis est ce
que nous nous voyons absolument pas
c'est un sujet qui nous préoccupe pas du
tout fait pas faire de mauvais esprit
mais on a passé toute la semaine
dernière en france a parlé du maréchal
pétain alors que la chine est en train
d'aligner des entreprises qui vont nous
nous sommes nous étions le 11 novembre
et hier la plus grosse entreprise de
e-commerce au monde alibaba dans ce qui
ne fait promotionnelle importante le 11
novembre en chine pas du tout pour les
mêmes raisons que nous c'est le jour des
célibataires là-bas 11 novembre un
séminaire ils font du commerce à tous
non mais oui bien sûr ahmed c'est le
parti communiste un clip comme vous
savez en train de fermer d'ailleurs les
universités marxiste en chine en ce
moment et ils ont réalisé plus de 30
milliards de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires dans la jours
mais voilà et nous nous nous prêtons
comptoir ne sais pas si on est
d'enquêter sur notre histoire parce que
le chinois pour des entreprises non mais
je pense qu'on a minima voire les deux
ah oui mais ça je me suis rallié je
voudrais vous poser une question
non parce que le soutien des amis c'est
vraiment un avenir donc c'est un sujet
non mais vous avez raison madame ce
sujet tellement larges comme on a plein
d'autres choses à dire encore du coup
chez elle les appelle je vous frustre
aussi bien sûr c'est pas de la mise en
relation des fonds seront garanties la
manade trump a quand même fait avancer
un certain nombre de dossiers et me dit
le multilatéraliste fonctionne mieux
mais c'est pas vrai sur la corée sur
l'iran je suis heureux sur l'économie il
a des résultats etc
il ne fonctionne pas et donc la méthode
d'un titre à moi j'aime pas mais lire à
son style non plus belle et efficace
pour l'un soyez vraiment concert
disparaître le fait que les nations
doivent les gens sont élevées pour
défendre les intérêts de leurs annonces
mais le mult opéra l'isthme est dans
notre intérêt c'est la raison pour
laquelle quand le dr romain à l'échelle
mondiale c'est compliqué c'est si
compliqué qu'on m'a malheureusement
devoir passer c'était celui-là avec
autant on va parler de gens qui
défendent apparemment assez bien leur
intérêt
nos confrères du parisien révèle ce
matin que l'ancien patron de force
ouvrière jean claude mailly été rémunéré
primes comprises sans 1334 euros par an
et puis il ya une autre enquête qui nous
annoncent les rémunérations des membres
des cabinets ministériels alors en
moyenne on est un peu plus un peu au
dessus de 9000 euros autour de 9100
euros et figurez vous qu'il ya 80
membres de cabinets ministériels qui
gagnent plus que neuf mille neuf cent
quarante euros et 9900 40 euros par mois
c'est le salaire d'un ministre
alors est ce que c'est normal qu'un
membre de cabinet puisse gagner autant
voire plus qu un ministre nicolas bouzou
vous êtes plutôt libérale mais dans le
libéral et via l'offre et la demande
la non mais ce qui est pas alors je vais
pas choqué beaucoup mais peut-être pas
trop au figaro mais ce qui est anormal
c'est que les ministres gagne pas plus
c'est pas le salaire des membres des
membres de cabinet qui me
de calcul et vous travailler 7 jours sur
7 22 heures sur 24 vous est corvéable à
merci vous avez plus de vie c'est pas
très intéressant ça donne quand même un
t1
c'est très difficile il ya le nombre de
personnes dans les cabinets a été réduit
ces dernières années donc vous voyez des
secrétariat d'état qui travaille avec
cinq ou six conseillers techniques donc
les gens sont véritablement et qui est
des lancker il en ressort des services
juste en 20 secondes et vous prendrez
vous percevez pas plus loin
je pense que nous avons un immense sujet
en france qu'il faudra bien traité qui
est celui de la rémunération des
ministres plus des élus qui à mon avis
est beaucoup trop faible
donc pour vous ça n'est pas choquant que
les membres de cabinets soit soit soit
bien payé
on a interrogé sur ce sujet benjamin
griveaux ce matin c'est le porte parole
du gouvernement
parce que la rémunération moyenne dans
son cabinet a augmenté de 27% par
rapport à son prédécesseur
et bien lui ça le dérange pas d'ailleurs
il s'en explique tout à fait sereinement
c'était ce matin sur europe 1 c'est donc
27 % d'augmentation pourquoi parce que
mes conseils sont plus expérimentés et
on sont plus âgés que les conseillers
qui étaient là auparavant est-ce que je
suis très au dessus de la moyenne en
moyenne des cabinets ministériels je
suis 2% au-dessus très exactement 2 2%
au-dessus pas choqué par ces niveaux de
rémunération on l'a on est sur des
cabinets ministériels après on parlera
de force au voyage
je suis entièrement d'accord
nicolas c'est absolument inaudible
aujourd'hui pour les français personne
il ya quiconque va ce soir sur une
grande chaîne de télé ou demain selon
radio et tient les propos de nicolas il
se fait étriper par la grande majorité
de français
il ya un problème de rapport à
l'économie libérale à l'argent aux
salaires alors chier des syndicalistes
et chez des ministres alors puissance
puissance mille
parce que non plus par le salaire de
jean claude mailly non parce que 100000
avec primes quand on dit quand on dit
ils se parent 12 janvier en hongrie
quand on divise par douze tours pour un
des princes a fait tomber mais je vous
répète c'est invendable sur la place
publique aujourd'hui absolument un
vandale et et contrairement à ce qu'on a
cru ça fait des années qu'on dit le
rapport des français à l'argent est en
train de changer de se détendre
compagnie je crois que c'est exactement
le contraire dans dans la machine
idéologique qui est la nôtre aujourd'hui
au contraire c'est plus en plus
difficile ça se tend de plus en plus il
ya de plus en plus de jugement de valeur
sur la question de l'argent et c'est une
question très importante pour la société
française
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
pour l'instant deux intervenants sur ce
plateau trouve que ce sont pas des
rémunérations abusives on va écouter les
deux autres mais avant on va écouter les
internautes
on leur a posé la question on vous a
posé la question sur twitter est-ce que
syndicat cabinets ministériels sont ils
trop payés eh bien vous répondez oui à
88 % ce qui est tout à fait raccord avec
les français trouvent que c'est trop
mais mais mais mais et on fait aussi du
qualitatif dans point de vue et donc
voici quelques témoignages ils ne sont
pas à la hauteur ils ont tellement
davantage nous dit servent donc ça c'est
plutôt critique en revanche anti mac
nous dit je ne suis pas choqué cent
mille euros c'est un salaire normal pour
un dirigeant syndical le même anti mac
10 mai un pdg est bien au dessus et r3
nous dit il faut mieux ça que des
valises sous la table et manu emmanuel
macron alexandre ii vecchio
non moi je ne suis pas choqué par le
le niveau des rémunérations des cabinets
je pense qu'en plus il travaillait plus
peut-être que les ministres donc donc
c'est pas chaud pro après ça m'amuse pas
mal et je pense que c'est un des noeuds
du problème que ça tombe sur benjamin
griveaux qui accueille il ya quelques
jours à 10h les électeurs de wauquiez
ceux qui roulent en diesel et ceux qui
fument des clopes ça ça me faisait
penser à marie-antoinette avec donnez
leur de la brioche donc c'est aussi pour
ça que les gens soient aussi épidermique
parce qu'il ya une forme d'arrogance du
pouvoir conjuguer à une certaine
incompétence a fait 40 ans que la laque
on ne sort pas du problème du chômage
qui à un certain nombre de problèmes qui
ne sont pas réglés et je pense que si
les politiques étaient efficaces la
question ne se poserait pas grave vous
avez raison les politiques se sont payés
le pauvre laurent wauquiez
malheureusement pour lui il n'a pas 80
88 % des sondés de son côté non plus ça
va ça veut dire que c'est quasiment
toute la population française toutes
classes sociales confondues toutes
sensibilités politiques confondues
donc c est je crois que la question de
l'argent est une question éthique on
semble au coeur de la cité française
isabelle celui d'abord je suis d'accord
je voulais juste ajouter une précision à
ce que disait nicolas s'était par
exemple je sais que j'ai blanc caire ils
sont dix conseillers
c'est à dire pour un ministère aussi
gigantesque ces gens là n'ont absolument
plus donc je suis absolument d'accord
avec ce que vous avez dit mais moi
j'aimerais revenir aux racines de ce que
de ce que
norris est grand parce que moi j'ai le
droit chez les abeilles pour dire que
jean michel blanquer air sera dans ce
studio pour audition publique
notre émission de fin de journée et je
vous passe travaux bravo non mais c'est
bien de l'interroger et doit mettre le
confrère dès le cp je pense je suis
d'accord et moi c'est ça que j'appelle
les passions tristes cet absolu volonté
de regarder dans l'assiette du voisin
cette obsession que l'autre est plus que
soi ou là là quelle horreur et ça qu'il
me semble quand même que il ya du lourd
de responsabilités à gauche parce que
j'ai encore en tête un certain françois
hollande et ses diatribes non suivi
d'ailleurs du moindre effet et si vous
voulez l'obsession de la transparence de
dites nous combien vous gagnez 2 faisons
des lois pour dire combien chacun gagne
il ya certainement quelque chose de
chaud lula derrière moi je trouve que
c'est des passions vraiment c'est ce que
stendhal appelé qui est un jeune appelé
ça justement la jalousie l'envi lan
impuissante et je trouve ça mais
détestable arrêtons ce truc
et arrêtons de dire que c'est normal
tant pis si on se fait déchirer moi je
crois qu'il faut dire la vérité nous
quand ils le patron d'une des quatre ou
cinq plus grandes cinq centrales
syndicales françaises tu dois tenir un
certain rang dans ses discussions avec
mes hôtes et machin je dire à être payé
7 7 me le net pense par mois 16 ans à
peu près c'est très bien mais bon ça
fait pas de vous un super prix viré
c'est pas évident nicolas vous de
trouver le juste salaire pour des
membres de cabinets ministériels ou des
patrons syndicats parce que
d'entreprises privées c'est assez simple
quand il ya des règles de concurrence si
on paye pas assez les gens ils s'en vont
chez les autres mais là c'est pas le cas
alors comment on fait c'est quoi le sait
quoi le juste la juste rémunération dans
votre question il n'y a pas de juste
rémunération mais on peut regarder ce
qui se passe par rapport au secteur
privé je vais prendre non pas l'exemple
des cabinets ministériels que je connais
moins bien mais celui des élus eux mêmes
celui des ministres comparez ce qu'il
gagne par rapport à ce poste qui
pourrait en règle générale gagner dans
une entreprise privée
la différence elle est énorme donc après
il faut pas s'étonner si on a une crise
des vocations chez les élus et même si
au sein du gouvernement
vous avez un certain nombre de gens qui
se disent aujourd'hui mais au fond si on
m'appelle pourquoi j'irai au
gouvernement je vais gagner deux à trois
fois moins
la presse va être en permanence sur mon
dos
j'aurai je serai dans un gouvernement en
plus diriger qui est inquiet extrêmement
centralisé
je suis pas sûr de réussir et que quand
je vais en sortir dans deux ou trois ans
comprenez bien qu'il ya un problème
d'attractivité majeur à d'abord voulu
steve derniers mots de maurice a franchi
à ce sujet l'argent par exemple nous les
journalistes dans les ya 20 ou 30 ans ou
40 ans dans les dix premiers de sciences
po il y avait toujours deux ou trois qui
allaient dans le journalisme
plus aucun aujourd'hui plus aucun 0
parce que c'est un métier de c'est un
métier de pauvres par rapport à ce que
quelqu'un qui sort de sciences po peut
obtenir dans la finance dans la pub dans
la banque et c'est donc la question du
rapport à l'argent dans la société
française est une question absolument
crucial et qui cache la tête de la
révolution sur juste une question pour
maurice szafran vous avez pas
mentalement réagi comme ça au moment de
la sphère fillon rappelle qu'il est
quand même tombé pour l'histoire de
costumes ministre de lancer très
différent on est exactement la même
chose il ya une forme d'arroseur arrosé
du tout dans ce rapport on a senti que
la même chose lui doit aussi le dernier
mot reste aux internautes
barnier sur le tchat s'il vous plaît
chers amis c'est moi qui parle pour
l'instant
barnier sur le chat du figaro je crois
que c'est absolument ça n'est pas michel
naudy reprend cette expression célèbre
c'est encore mieux en anglais payer des
cacahuètes et vous aurez des singes
edouard nous dit les français n'ont
aucune idée de ce que gagne un ingénieur
du corps des mines de 40 ans c'est
largement plus c'est de fait qu'allusion
à grands corps de l'état dont viennent
souvent les membres des cabinets
ministériels alors que nicole sur le
chat du figaro nous nous dit qu'ils
financent les syndicats enfin un dernier
mot ce qui rejoint un peu le propos de
nicolas bouzou
edwards sur le chat nous dit un jeune
conseiller en cabinet qui part dans le
privé se voit facilement proposer le
double de sa rémunération
il nous reste quelques minutes pour
parler encore d'argent mais cette
fois-ci de l'argent que les gens n'ont
pas ou qui n'ont plus à cause des taxes
évidemment parler de la journée de
samedi prochain le 17 novembre un
mouvement assez spontané semble-t-il
veut bloquer les routes pour protester
entre autres contre l'augmentation des
taxes sur le gasoil alors qui sont ces
gens qui veulent bloquer le pays sont
ils dangereux sont ils des fâché au des
fachos c'est le l'alternative
ou plus exactement l'explication le
décryptage qu'on faisait jean luc
mélenchon c'était jeudi dernier à pau
souvenez vous le 17 novembre est une
auto organisation populaire dont je
souhaite le succès et je vais vous le
dire les avis il faut souhaiter son
succès on me dit il ya des fois chaud là
dedans
oui oui il y en a partout il ya aussi
beaucoup de fâcher qui sont pas facho et
cela ils ont raison d'être fâché et moi
je suis pour à l'étrier sur les bancs
donc à jean luc mélenchon qui est tout à
fait favorable à ce mouvement
ça n'est pas le cas de laurent berger
autres patrons syndicales dont je ne
connais pas le salaire mais c'est le
secrétaire national de la cfdt
il était ce matin sur france info et lui
dit arrêtons de nous cacher les yeux la
vérité c'est que ce mouvement
il est organisé par l'extrême droite
regardez la cfdt elle comprend
l'exaspération d'un certain nombre de
salariés qui pour se rendre au travail
ou un coût supplémentaire mais soutient
pas ces blocages dont tout le monde a
compris qu ils sont en plus récupérer
politiquement par l'extrême droite est
effectivement lancement n'était pas
juste car laurent berger n'a pas dit
qu'il était organisée mais récup
extrêmement avait d'ailleurs il a dit
que récupérer le verbatim sous les yeux
donc c'est moi qui avais tort est ce que
ça vous inquiète nicolas bouzou
intuitivement ce mouvement cette espèce
de jacquerie là oui ça m'inquiète parce
que je pense que le on confond le
déclencheur et la cause le déclencheur
c'est la hausse de la fiscalité sur le
carburant mais ce pas là aussi défilé de
fiscalité sur le carburant qui pose
problème en soi c'est la hausse de la
fifa on avait une très bonne fiscalité
extrêmement lisible avec d une vraie
diminution de la fiscalité appuyé sur
une baisse de la dépense publique que
tout ceci soit équitable et qu'on
introduit la fiscalité écologique je
pense pas qu'on serait dans la même
situation mais le problème c'est que la
fiscalité nous fallait politique fiscale
du gouvernement
pain est mauvais c'est à dire que grosso
modo on n'a pas de baisse de la
fiscalité et de l est absolument
incompréhensible
comme on le voit sur la question de la
fiscalité locale donc oui je pense que
les ressorts sont des héros sort qui
sont importants et oui ça m'inquiète
maurice szafran fâché ou facho fâché
avec comme le dit berges est l'ex front
national qui essayent effectivement
marine le pen étant extrêmement prudente
elle a encore dit ce matin qu'elle
resterait chez elle samedi mais qu'il
fallait absolument que les militants du
rassemblement national y aille je crois
que c'est un moment absolument
fondamental pour le point cayla
d'emmanuel macron la fameuse
mobilisation sociale n'avait pas
fonctionné cadre classique cgt et fo
cfdt soutenu par les partis de gauche ou
parce qu'il reste des partis de gauche
j'en appelle un sens table se mettre à
lyon personne absolument pas fonctionné
l'opposition politique à emmanuel macron
ne fonctionne absolument pas pour
l'instant
et peut-être n'y est peut-être que
peut-être que la vraie réponse au
maquereau nisme qui a surpris tout le
monde
quand il est apparu comme ça sur le
champ politique peut-être que la vraie
réponse au maquereau nive que la vraie
aux propositions macro nisme que la
vraie réponse sociale ou maquereau nisme
ça sera ce mouvement-là et et dans ces
cas là si ça fonctionne ça à devenir
extrêmement compliqué extrêmement
compliqué une toute dernière chose il
est vraiment gonflé mélenchon parce que
dans la france insoumise il ya des
qui ne veulent pas y aller parce qu'il
ya des fachos il ya des gens qui veulent
pas y aller parce qu'ils sont pour la
fiscalité ou qu écologique et c'est tout
à fait normal et des gens comme
mélenchon qui veulent y aller donc si un
parti qui souffrent vraiment de ce
mouvement de samedi prochain c'est la
france un sou ni alex en effet qu on se
pose la question est-ce que c'est
inquiétant
maurice szafran répond oui c'est
inquiétant politiquement pour emmanuel
macron mais est-ce que c'est inquiétant
pour la république parce que c'est un
mouvement qui n'est pas encadrée parce
qu' il peut y avoir des dérives des
dérapages alors j'attends le moment où
faute de solution politique mâcon va
nous expliquer que les îles et jaune
soit en réalité des chemises brunes
ca c c'est une possibilité mais non on
sait pas c'est pas inquiétant pour la
république mais c'est inquiétons pour la
fracturation malgré tout de la société
française effectivement ce moment c'est
l'expression de la fraude de la fameuse
france périphérique de christophe
guilluy de ces gens qui n'ont parfois
pas les moyens de se chauffer ou parfois
pas les moyens de de faire un plein donc
là on voit qu'il ya une coupure réel
entre une population qui profitent de la
mondialisation et tant mieux qui vit
dans les grandes métropoles une certaine
élite et le reste de la population
française et que le dialogue entre les
deux est de plus en plus compliqué ce
qui est inquiétant aussi c'est qu'on est
dans une société où il n'y a plus aucun
corps intermédiaires ils vont bien
chercher parce qu'ils étaient de moins
en moins représentatifs
macron a d'ailleurs accélérer le
mouvement et là il se retrouve
effectivement c'est inquiétant
politiquement pour lui seul face à une
espèce de vague de vague populaire qui
sans doute peut aller très loin
mais on voit pas très bien comment elle
peut se traduire politiquement c'est ça
qui est un peu qui est un peu gênante
pour l'instant il n'ya pas d'incarnation
et c'est vrai que c'est inquiétant pour
le débat démocratique c'est la question
du jour sur lefigaro.fr et bien sûr
elisabeth lévy pour ap pourra parler
j'aime beaucoup charlize avec qu'on vous
indigner contre une censure possible
mais rassurez vous il est toujours
possible surtout ici et le figaro.fr
où on vous pose la question pensez vous
que la mobilisation de samedi sera
d'ampleur bien vous pourrez vous pensez
plutôt oui il y a cinq ans f voilà 50 1%
plus de 16 mille votants on rappelle que
beaucoup ce sont des points de vue
exprimés mais mais pas un sondage
ras-le-bol des attaques contre les
automobilistes 80 km/heure ph parking
taxe nous sommes des vaches à lait nous
dit élan sur le chat du figaro anti mac
nous dit le vrai problème ce n'est pas
le prix de l'essence et l'accumulation
des augmentations d'impôts depuis des
années
cette hausse de l'essence n'est qu'un
prétexte c'est la goutte d'eau nous dit
lutins cantat babineau ils voient pas
l'intérêt de la mobilisation en disant
de toute façon macron ne fera pas
machine arrière
il avait sévi sur repose ma question est
ce que ça vous inquiète pour la vie
démocratique de notre pays un mouvement
comme ça car je pense que c'est bien
voyez alexandra déjà y ait une grande
partie de ce que j'aurais pu dire il
vaut mieux donc je suis d'accord mais ce
qui m'inquiète non non pas du tout ce
qui m'inquiète c'est on a l'impression
que c'est à d'éternelles suspects dans
ce pays parce que on parle de quoi on
parle de classe moyenne peut-être de
classes moyennes et de classes
populaires d'ailleurs de la france
périphérique et englobe maintenant cette
grande classe moyenne en voie de
disparition et ce sont toujours eux qui
sont soupçonnés des guides des qui les
bleus dès qu'il est bleu d'été qui n'est
qui rouspètent sur quoi que ce soit ils
sont soupçonnés d'être façon d'être et
les médias personne n'a posé cette
question
le ski est spectaculaire c'est pris très
au sérieux ce mouvement il est pris au
sérieux et coûteuse en mairie au service
avec qui je vous pose la question à bord
il y avait un raisonnement que j'ai
oublié donc maintenant ça serait beau
nom alors je remarque qu'à luz avec eux
parfois pour la vivacité du débat il
vous arrivera mais il a été repéré vous
interromps pas de couper complètement
les gens dans un raisonnement jeu
surtout auto répondre à un truc qui
disait pas donc je ne sais plus de jouer
alors moi je fais quelque chose ça
commence à peler cinématiques ne pas
pouvoir avoir déroulé en argument sans
être interrompu et ça c'est aussi tout
ce qui fait le sel du débat la dette
alors quand même que au début le
gouvernement emmanuel macron lui-même
avait dit que ces gens veulent surtout
bloqué la france qui s'était assez
critique et puis là ce discours critique
il a disparu un comme si comme s'il y
avait une forme de compréhension nous
avec eux
dans notre sondage et et je pense que je
sais pas peut-être de quoi tu m'aurais
s'apprend dépôt d'écouter les français
maurice apprend qu'il leur dit qu'il
faut écouter les français non mais je
veux dire à l'évidence ils doivent se
rendre compte qu'il se passe quelque
chose qu'ils ont fait une grossière
erreur avec cette api sphère de prêchi
prêcha écologique sur une taxe qui
l'approchent mans dévise écologique
depuis une semaine
si voulez vous croyez que la rééducation
et écologique des masses campagnarde
c'est ça qu'il faut en ce moment je
pense que macro l'a compris ballon et je
pense que effectivement
et pense que là comme l'a dit maurice il
ya probablement un touriste et je le
crois je crois que s'ils n'entendent pas
là s'ils sont complètement hermétique à
skis et l'anthropologie aussi de ce pays
eh bien je veux dire il aura vraiment
raté je pense son quinquennat pour nous
ça va ça va dépendre de ce qui se passe
de ce qui se passe samedi
s'il ya une grosse mobilisation s'il ya
une très grosse mobilisation
il ya un vrai problème politique ce qui
est mais je crois qu'ils savent d'ores
et déjà savent très bien à l'elysée qui
aura une grosse mobilisation samedi et
ils ne sont pas dupes de ce qu en train
de se casser la réponse qui est
importante non rien su à quel peut-être
non qu'est ce qu'elle peut être alors
aucune idée je me demande si maurice
vous dramatisez par un peu à dessin on
vous disant que la mobilisation sera pas
aussi immense que ça moi je pense ne
sera pas immense dans le sens où
malheureusement on est dans une société
liquide atomisé individualiste et que
malgré tout j'ai dit tout à l'heure les
échos ramade intermédiaires sont pas
très représentative mais son doux et
quand même pour rassembler mobiliser
l'argent donc je pense qu'on va aller
vers une forme de démocratie directe
les gens vont finir par réussir à se
rassembler mais là on n'y est pas tout à
fait et je pense que la mobilisation va
pas être autant d'ampleur que ça et que
vous pourrez dire maquereau a gagné sauf
que l'inquiétude localement des
réglisses d'organiser ça nous fait
l'inquiétude dans le pays est réel
quelle que soit quelle que soit la
mobilisation finale r je pense que la
mobilisation individualiste qui al'air
contradictoires c'est ce qui va très
bien fonctionné futur il ne fonctionne
pas c'est la mobilisation par les corps
intermédiaires mais on serait en train
de changer les merci à tous les culs les
autres un dernier mot à nos internautes
d'abord au fan-club d'elisabeth lévy qui
s'est mobilisée immédiatement à l'idée
qu'en plus je quittais ma parole
elisabeth lévy souffre mais pourtant
elle est pleine de bon sens et de vérité
et
et bon sang je dis cela ce qui est la
raison madame lévis et je laisse le
dernier des derniers mots de la fin aspi
temps avec cette jolie formule je ne
sais pas si les gilet jaune sont fâchés
ou facho mais les personnalités
politiques de gauche qui les méprise
sont des fachos bonsoir à tous
[Musique]